I'm now going to introduce an ancient
method for generating a list of primes
up to some limit n called the sieve of
eratosthenes now Eratosthenes was born
in 276 BC so this method you know is
over 2200 years old but it's very simple
and elegant and you could teach it to
any child now let's say for example we
want to calculate all the primes up to a
hundred but this would work in the same
way if we wanted to calculate up to ten
thousand or a billion it proceeds as
follows assume all numbers are unmarked
gray is unmarked we start at the
beginning and if we find a number that
is unmarked we know its prime so we hit
two and we say two is prime because it's
unmarked and then the second phase is
now we can eliminate all multiples of
two because we know they're composite so
BAM we jump along and we eliminate all
multiples two of two red means composite
and now we repeat we step along from two
to three three is unmarked so we mark
three is prime and now we can eliminate
all multiples of three and a really
simple optimization as notice six is
already crossed off we actually cross
off the multiples starting at the square
of that number so three times three is
nine
we start at nine and Mark all multiples
of three as composite and again we go
back we jump along to four well four is
marked we know it's composite then we
jump along to five we found an unmarked
number five is prime now five times five
is twenty-five we go to 25 we mark off
25 30 35 40 45 and so on those are
composites we proceed forward until we
hit seven we know seven is prime because
it's unmarked seven times seven is
forty-nine we marked 49 and all
multiples of seven above it as composite
and now we move along until we hit 11 11
is prime and notice now 11 times 11 is
greater than 100 so we
actually stop at this point we could
have stopped at ten even because now all
remaining unmarked numbers if you'll
notice our prime and we could in one
swoop mark them all as Prime and that's
the whole algorithm it's so simple and
just to generalize how we do this so we
could write up a program to perform this
sieve is if we want to find all Prime's
up to some number n we first create a
main loop so we have for all numbers a
from two to the square root of n so
notice here we stopped when we hit ten
or if I showed it as 11 we actually
stopped because we have found all
Prime's so from 2 to the square root of
n we proceed as follows if a is unmarked
then we know a is prime and when we find
a prime number we mark all multiples of
a off as composite and that's it so you
find a number prime mark off the
multiples go back to the beginning
increment a by one so we're on 2 then we
go to 3 then we go to 4 or 5 and so on
and when we're done we have all Prime's
notice here that this is also a loop so
we have a main loop 4 and when we find a
prime this marking off of multiples is
also a loop so it's important to notice
here that we have a nested loop we have
a loop inside a loop here is an example
of this algorithm in action I wrote in
JavaScript below if I put in a hundred
here are all the primes under 100 and if
I put in 200 here are all the primes
under 200 and if I put in 850 here are
all the primes under 850 and below I
have this program with a recording
explaining how I set it up